have you ever had a dream you had one
no i have it's really weird and what is
yours like it was it was
good it was good it was a
nice size yeah it was a nice
girth yeah
and it was a shower not a grower
i was like touching it and i'm like i
heard someone say recently that when you
love someone there is no body part that
you would not put in your mouth except
eyeballs so don't be looking eyeballs oh
[ __ ] there's something no body part
you would lick the inside of a nostril
who regularly dreams about someone else
in this room hmm
i had a lesbian dream about tiff one
what
[Music]
hi
welcome back to another episode of big
mood and uh who do we have here today we
have a very special guest here who is
she tell us what's your name nikki blade
and we have another special guest we'll
know she's main cast but she's still so
special to me
she's special she's special who are you
tiff yeah
thank you yeah and i am also very
special to my own special special way
it's me gina hi
uh okay so today's episode i bought a
new game and look i i [ __ ] love card
games i love games i love card games
they're fun like they're fun you get to
know each other i have like 12 of these
and i bought a new one and i strong
armed my way into playing this game
because i want to get to know everyone
uh the game is called the voting game
where voting it's basically like a game
of like who's more likely to
pull a card that says who's more likely
to [ __ ]
hit a curb with their car and then we
vote on who like gina yeah like me you
know
however
i don't really want to play it that way
i want to play it like um
let's pull a card and then if you have a
story that goes to that card
or if that card pertains to you tell us
the story tell us why okay and then
instead of passing the box around i'm
just going to give everyone a stack and
then we're going to oh and yeah we're
going to pull one by one so here tiff
last time somebody said i'm gonna give
you a stack it was money i'm sorry oh
lucky i've never been told that what
oh going to the script club with a stack
no but i want the money for myself i
love scriptures but let me keep this
all right so uh i'll pull first okay so
we can get a general feel
um let me see
all right
whose real name would make the best porn
star name we already know
right here hello i just found out her
real name is actually blades yeah that's
her legal name yeah that's cool i can't
believe you just have that name for free
i got lucky for free i know right yeah
yeah
blades yeah so sharp
i really want to drop my first name i
just want to be blaze yeah you can just
refer to me as i mean we already refer
to you as blades in our group because we
already have a nicki yeah so we're just
like blades and a lot of groups have a
nicki already so
i just want to be blades you could just
refer to me as blades now cool that's it
the artist is formerly known as nikki
boyce
yes it's so dramatic yeah i love it
that's me i love it okay wait if you
could have if you could change your name
to be a porn star name what would it be
well i always liked this uh the name
that i would give out when i would go to
clubs that i didn't want to tell them my
real name i was always naomi i just
always felt sexy to me like just such a
sexy name
so i would be like naomi something you
should be naomi blades just add blades
to everything to everybody just add
links to everything yeah i like it
there's a song called uh kokomiyaki okay
so my name would be coco miyaki i'm not
even japanese am i appropriating
whatever i'm close enough
[Music]
[ __ ] comment me in the comments
um
blades i didn't tell you the funniest
part though
every time yeah
it's good
that sounds like a baseball player coco
puffs
it kind of reminds me of that
i don't know why i thought you were
gonna say like that should be my
nickname or my stripper name or porn
star name coco puffs
maybe i don't know
what your trick is
no um
i could never spell naomi
every time people would ask me for my
number i mean like oh yeah and then i
would spell it so [ __ ] up in the phone
because i just didn't know i for the
life of me i can't remember how to spell
that name no wait that's how you want
your name to be but you don't know how
to write your own name i don't know it's
like
n
a
i
o no wait
see it could be it's all it's your name
and
you can make it whatever you want i mean
look at all these white people they're
hating braden kate and jaden you know
like that's true and they spell it with
twos and [ __ ]
but there is like a right way to spell
it sure and then there's your way i just
don't know what the red n-a-o-m-i
n-a-o-n
i don't know it's close enough for me
all right guys they're cute i could put
little hearts over them
what's your name
i i
there's somebody watching this right now
like these girls
let's put these three on a spelling bee
be careful
oh my goodness
okay
who spends the most time thinking about
their eggs
hmm
i would vote
this one right here yeah really yeah
probably oh
yeah
yeah probably okay not intentionally
yeah i got to get a new one so i can
stop thinking about the whole thing
i'm not living in the past yeah i would
like to live in someone's present but
you know unfortunately some of y'all
[ __ ] don't know how to act
but the good news is you will you are in
someone's future
fortune cookie confucius
sounded like a fortune cookie over here
naomi
maybe i'm part
[Laughter]
chinese let me see
um
who hit snooze on their alarm clock at
least five times before getting out of
bed
let me show you something real quick all
right if you can zoom in let me show you
something
how many alarms you got girl i gotta
show you my phone too but i don't have
it on oh i do
yep that's me too
look at all those
all of us
from
look at this
yeah
from midnight
to 11 59pm yep dude i have from 1 30 a.m
to 10 45 p.m how i got 5 p.m 5 p.m 5 p.m
5 10 5 10 5 20.
apparently that's what time the my
second half of my day starts oh god it's
so funny yeah most of mine are like
early a.m because i'm like every 15
minutes or every five minutes sometimes
yeah i need an alarm i don't know why i
have a midnight one
i'm trying to figure that why do i have
a midnight one what am i just thinking
midnight that needs an alarm stream
probably knowing you no not even that
late i don't you have to remind yourself
to drink water oh
yeah i do need to do that yeah that's
sad okay um let me see girl that's bad i
know it's a whole hydroflask
yeah they're the ones who sent me that
water cooler oh oh wow yeah that's my
favorite box they're like [ __ ] you're
dying like they actively all of them
together try to keep me alive they are
your village yeah they are they're
adorable and i love them
um okay who would have the most fun
going to a nightclub alone
alone yeah by myself i feel like you
would have fun everywhere you go oh uh
surprise no no um i don't like she
doesn't give me those vibes
no i go with a purpose
i do not like going to nightclub by
myself
i like to give the illusion that i do
but i'm i hate people
people like
people don't know how to act guys are
really weird and girls are really
strange and nightclubs are a scary place
if you don't know anybody i have gone
but i knew somebody there
but if i'm not the type of person to go
into a nightclub by myself a bar
strangely enough i'm probably more
confident in going into a barbecue i
could do a bar in a restaurant all day
by myself okay but nightclub no i'm fine
with the bar too i can't imagine
why would anyone want to go to a
nightclub by themselves there are plenty
of people that do like guys guys i get i
get why they would but a girl why are
you yeah why is that mary yo if you like
to go to the clubs by yourself tell us
why down below
i don't like going anywhere alone
that's like that like a bar
no i'll do a restaurant by myself but
definitely not a nightclub yeah no
nightclub um
yeah i don't know
i can't see myself okay going to that
environment alone yeah that's weird it
is weird like what do you do yeah i mean
drink and have fun or dance some people
actually do go and dance but
okay who gives the best life advice
oh me oh you were gonna pick me yeah no
way yeah wow yeah good for us i think
both of y'all because i mean obviously
like you are full of advice thank you
and you i feel like i learned a lot of
things from you really yeah thanks
that surprises me and i feel like it's a
good balance because you have a
different life experience
yeah you do a good job of like not
judging i think that's
people that give the best advice don't
judge as much and they probably like
live through it you've lived through
some [ __ ] girl that's true that's true
that is my life i'm gonna go ahead and
ignore that no one pointed at me yeah no
gina you are not giving the like we love
you and i love you you give grievances
give you the vibe
great bad advice oh my god yes if you
want a good laugh and know what not to
do that's a girl right here
we're taking care of you baby girls
like if you want to do life well and
healthy these two if you want to get
interesting
maybe you're arrested yeah and i'm the
hybrid
i'm more likely they are i'm more likely
to tell you all the great things you
should do and then do what gina does
yeah
did you know that to make a body
decompose faster you put yogurt in their
anus oh see life and why
um probiotics
are bacteria
weird we all have our strong suits here
and if i ever kill somebody i'm calling
gina
he's there hey callie tim i feel like
you freaked out actually no you got a
little gangster inside of you i don't
know for sure yeah she's born and raised
in tijuana
i like that
born and raised i'm gonna come over here
hey you're on a roll today i want to
come over with a bucket of oikos like i
got you
where's the body the greek yogurt
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay i like this one
who can't walk more than a block without
saying hi to someone they know
ooh
i feel like you know a lot of people you
know a lot of people yeah i mean i'm
sure you know a lot of people too but i
know her more yeah i think he knows so
many people yeah you know a lot of
people yeah possibly it does have pretty
often every time we go to an event you
know someone uh remember we used to go
to events all the time i know i miss
those i like to vote with you guys yeah
invite me because i don't get invited
anymore influencer events i don't think
they just they just don't have them
anymore well yeah sure it's quite good
yeah they're very interesting
and then we got a whole bunch of other
stuff in the air nowadays so monkey pox
and [ __ ] yeah
yeah those are fun we got every time we
always would run into some wishing yeah
i believe it totally i can see it
oh
uh what's your giggling out over there
please let me see
who would be your one phone call if you
got arrested
one of my white friends
i'm calling my girl ariel
she would know what to do she oh i have
her number memorized
call my white friend if i get arrested
i'm calling my white friend she knows
exactly what protocols and steps to take
in case [ __ ] went down yeah her or my
other white friend laura shout out to my
white friends
baby knowing
you know what's so funny about that i
think i would probably call jess over
casey your boyfriend where's my
boyfriend that's true
yeah i i think my first call would be to
casey to let him know what happened to
me but if you only get the woman and
tell him to call
him to call jess because i know he's not
going to know what to do [ __ ] i'd borrow
jess too yeah
yeah yeah for sure
uh let's see i think the only number
well i mean she's been my emergency
contact since i was a kid because her
number is so damn easy to remember it's
my aunt
yeah it's my aunt which is my cousin's
mom and he lives with me okay um so i
would tell her
she's the only number i i remember and
then just have her spread the word and
find my lawyers or something but she has
been like i don't even know if she knows
that she's my emergency
for anything
because her number is literally like
one two three five four five four yeah
eight nine eight nine like it's just so
easy she's had that since height like
when i was in high school yeah yeah
shout out to our white friends and
aunties
yeah actually i think casey's phone
number's the only number and my own is
the only number that i know now i don't
even know isaac's number by heart oh
oh but it is like he is it is a new
phone yeah he just got it
in case he's had his number for a long
time yeah since we've been dating oh wow
the same number yeah 10 years hmm uh who
would have the hardest time talking
their way out of an insane asylum
talking to we're out of it we know how
to get into one
i'm getting out of it i don't know i
definitely can't get out of one
you can't get out of here they look at
you and they said harley quinn send her
out
i would either vote gina or me yeah
for sure you are you can't communicate
for [ __ ] i'd be like up but i'll like uh
they're like we thought she was crazy
she just made me ignorant
her english is just bad all of a sudden
you don't know how to speak english i
just i just can't compute words in my
brain oh my god you're gonna get wow all
of a sudden you forget english
you'll be stuck in there you're gonna
have to get a translator sent in for you
your husband's gonna be like wait she
doesn't speak english anymore
she call him up he's like no my wife
definitely knows how to speak english
i'm sorry i'm like
i don't remember like
i'm not crazy i'm not crazy i think i
would be able to charm my way out you
know yeah probably yeah but because
i feel like i don't know because you
give me like there you're you have such
a person like duality to your
personality or one half it's like baby
is scared help me get me out of here and
the other side is badass i know how to
decompose a body with you
in somebody's anus yeah
so i don't know which one you would pick
i can turn it on and off if i had to get
out i think i can do it yeah imagine
like would a crazy person do this
like
[ __ ] my hand just drawing pictures
oh i see
[ __ ] finger
shipping
oh that is funny yeah you don't think
you could get yourself out no i could i
think you could i think you are such an
eloquent speaker i like to downplay it
oh for sure i'm getting out of there
what
you kidding me i made it this far in
life yeah i'm not gonna be able to get
out of
there that [ __ ] that's why i was
surprised i'm like i believe you could
get out i like to downplay it sometimes
like to be modest
oh my god i'm not that good at speaking
i'm gonna be stuck in there forever oh
my god she'll make friends in there
she'll get worse she's just like i don't
want to go that's great it's like first
off they love me they bought me a water
cooler
they're concerned about my hydration
i know says goddess over here
okay who is most easily seduced
you have you have seduced the both of us
in many ways
who would be the most i think like
younger gina would be easily seduced
now just like
not really i hate all of you
every single one we do swell we subdue
swag we seduce well so i would have to
say between the two between all of us
you would probably be the easiest to
subdue because we know the game because
i think i've almost tried yeah yeah no
yeah you almost succeeded i almost
succeeded yeah not trying
we almost succeeded what that's
something we'll talk about later okay
all right that was great it's a great
story i'm like the most gullible the
most easily persuaded the most easily
seduced yeah i just believe everyone is
always being honest so if you're telling
me something i will believe it yeah it's
a blessing and a curse
i think it's more i mean it's a blessing
for the rest of us i mean [ __ ]
it's a blessing for others yeah it's a
curse for you
all right now i know i'm not the only
one that has noticed inflation is
hurting from cringing at the pump to
getting an eye-popping check at your
favorite restaurant it is insane that's
why i started using upside upside is an
incredible app for anyone who buys gas
groceries or dines out with every
purchase i'm earning cashback thanks to
upside now currently i'm on a road trip
across new england and upstate new york
and i've been using upside at the pump
at grocery stores and at restaurants
just recently we ate at this wings
restaurant and i actually got 12
cashback so i've actually been really
loving upside to get started you
download the free upside app use our
promo code big mood to get five dollars
or more cash back on your first purchase
of 10 or more next claim an offer for
whatever you're buying on upside you
check in at the business pay as usual
with the credit or debit card and get
paid in comparison to credit card
rewards or loyalty programs you can earn
three times more cash back with upside
upside users are earning more than a
million dollars every week that's
probably why they have a 4.8 star rating
on the app store download the free
upside app and use promo code big mood
to get five dollars or more cash back on
your first purchase of ten dollars or
more that's five dollars or more cash
back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more using promo code big
mood who regularly dreams about someone
else in this room
hmm
i had a lesbian dream about tiff one
what
yeah and i am so painfully straight
like just painful i am painfully
straight it's [ __ ] it's
sorry
someone rewind the tape
rewind the tape because we have receipts
of you being not straight i know you are
you're a liar but when it comes down to
it i'm like i'm so strange she's a lie i
don't believe you i've tried
woman before oh yeah yeah oh like and
then i was like damn i am so straight
but you're not painfully straight your
line is a little i i feel like you you
made me one more time i feel like i am
so like i i love beautiful women i
acknowledge i hype but when it comes
down to like sexual relationships you
can't do it okay yeah but i wouldn't say
painfully straight you're not painful
okay i'm okay go ahead okay yeah okay
like you're straight but you're not
painfully shy [ __ ] there's too much
evidence of you being real confused you
know i was like maybe i want to turn
maybe
maybe it's just her my women are
beautiful my god heterosexuality's
wasted on me
stupid why you think i would if i had a
choice you think i would choose men no
she sucks me i know i agree i i'm mostly
straight too
it's just in the fantasy world is when
i'm not but in the reality world
i am this conversation would be
dramatically different if there was
alcohol presented in front of these two
women
i'm calling
the color called bluff okay as somebody
who's been the object of some googly ass
on
youtube i like to say this is your sober
mind talking cause that was that was in
fantasy worlds yeah it was in reality
world liquor in your liquor world yeah
that's why that was fantasy yeah that's
why we drink coffee when i come around
apparently we're not allowed to have
alcohol no more
when i come to set it's like real dry i
want to hear about this dream off camera
i don't want to give them to you for
free yeah yeah not for free not for free
not for free
okay
damn like my feet
okay who has the lowest passenger rating
on uber passenger rating oh like a bad
passenger i think i've been pretty good
i'm a good passenger oh remember that
one time when we all got shit-faced
drunk and we had yeah we had to have him
pull over in the freeway for me to puke
yeah sorry
i yeah we both puked yeah you got a bad
uber score for sure yeah oh [ __ ] with
you too yeah you got a bad uber score
for me
that's the same thing the same day
the same thing same thing to hear the
story yeah it's happening here yeah yeah
not for free
for free
for free yeah i know i think i would
probably get that then yeah no but you
actually vomited in the car
outside the car it was just a little
teeny bite yeah she caught it in her
hand
okay
did it surprise you
it did it did what song were we singing
what
about who was the oldest when they had
their first kiss
well how old were you guys i had mine at
i want to say
12.
i think i was
sixth grade how old are you that's 12
years eleven twelve-ish twelve yeah no
no eleven yeah only twelve-ish yeah okay
my
history is a little weird mm-hmm but i
would call like my official first kiss
when i was 13. okay okay so that's the
oldest one
yeah i remember my first case it was
like this boy had a crush on it was
summer school under a tree and i was
like oh it's so sweet and then he just
went [ __ ] full tongue in my mouth
like it was why is it so wet gross
don't like it yeah
um who will be the last person alive
out of this group yeah
me yeah
you have way more to live for you got
that [ __ ] in my room right now yeah but
i feel like she has way more survival
skills yeah i agree
she would totally live the longest
because i'm thinking
you know but no okay never mind
she said subtract herself from the
equation she's perfectly fine
she's her worst enemy
[Laughter]
but that makes sense
yeah i mean somebody's gonna she can get
persuaded into going to somebody's car
oh yeah
zombie apocalypse i'm the first one
going first one i'm gone yeah i'm laying
down i'm not i'm ready i don't want to
do it i'm really
bring it on i'm trying to test out all
these skills y'all can catch these two
for one special out here
i am ready i got a bat in my i got a bat
a racket a golf club a rocket a rock
a racket
can you imagine you know how badass
would that be just me with a rocket see
my crossbow
yeah christmas stick which done that
mm-hmm
you've done throwing axes i still
haven't done that pretty funny i really
wanted to realize
yeah it's true yeah yeah i look listen
the moment it is even suggested that we
have a new disease i'm already ready to
just label what happened with covid
almost any adults
like i'm not dealing with the [ __ ]
so there's even a hint
like sniff like not even a real official
website like it's snopes
you know i'm like all right
wait snope says
i don't know
this is a funny one
who will be having the most sex in the
retirement home
huh
for sure not me
yeah i should be getting that old dick
for sure oh for sure the geriatric dick
is gone
that the energizer bunny old people
homes are just riddled with stds well
because they don't care yeah why do they
need to care they don't stream they
dying their family don't care about them
that's true they just burn it in there
they do even get it up
that's what viagra you can get his
prescription for that or blue chew hmm
are you all spot are we sponsored by
bluetooth oh no i think at one point
maybe something around anyway i don't
know my other podcast response by
bluetooth keep in mind keeping them up
in the retirement home
oh
okay is it my turn yeah okay who cares
anymore you find a good one yell it out
all right
who has gotten a massage with a happy
ending
but who would oh
who would not like people touching me
there that just takes too much work i
don't know you mm-hmm
yeah
so much work yeah it's too much work
yeah there was a time
where this
i was gonna say where this tip
in the past would have said yes i would
have wanted to i would have been curious
because there was conversations about
like a place where they would finish
girls oh
that's interesting yeah i don't know
what that's about oh
so my curiosity was like yeah okay but
then now at this point i'm like yeah
i take too long they would charge me
another hour
that's how you know you like fed up with
people and you
just just take too [ __ ] long yeah
um who would look the best as the
opposite gender
you would yeah
beautiful eyes yes oh my god for sure
yeah yeah
i already know
yeah did you ever do that filter with
the beard and all that i look like my
dad it was terrible i mean my dad is
handsome but i look like my dad i was
like well it's terrible for you yeah i
want to know what you look like hell
yeah i would get first off if i could
get if i could get some [ __ ] now
i could get some [ __ ] as a man there
you go i feel maybe this is just my ego
talking
but i would have a good size number i
feel like
i feel like it wouldn't be too big but i
would know what to do with it do you
know what i'm saying like not
have you ever had a dream you had one no
i have it's really weird and what is
yours like oh uh i don't know like it
was it was good it was good it was a
nice size yeah it was a nice
girth yeah length and girth no but i was
in the bathroom trying to go pee oh
and it was a shower not a grower
[Music]
and good for you and then i just
remember feeling like whoa so this is
what it feels like to have have a penis
between your legs yeah it's weird and i
was like touching it and i'm like wow
that feels weird yeah and then i woke up
because i was like too into it i think
i would love to have a penis for a day
do you think what size would yours be
pretty average
i feel like you'd be a grower though
like you'd have to surprise somebody oh
yeah that would be nice you know what i
mean like they'd underestimate you
and then all of a sudden you're like
i'll show you a magic trick real quick
yeah that would be kind of cool that
would be kind of i feel like your
personality would fit a grower
i think so too
yeah yeah that would that would that
would that would be hilarious though
right like everybody was like oh i heard
ain't got nothing and then all of a
sudden you'd be like yeah let me see you
would be wearing gray sweatpants all day
year round oh swinging i would be
no matter where on the beach on the
beach you know just waiting in some gray
sweaters swimming pool yeah i would be
sweating there goes blaze
them gray sweatpants out here just
swinging for sure for sure
but i would be smooth i would be smooth
if i'm in pisces and i know some pisces
men
great lovers oh that would be
yeah i tap into my sensitive side but
i'd probably be a [ __ ]
a horn
you know that's
but i would be that you know like
there's some guys that you know that are
just trash yeah but you just want them
to pick you mm-hmm you know what i mean
like you know they ain't [ __ ] but you
just want to be that one that they
change for i'd be like
i feel like i'd be that man i'd be that
man that everybody would want like i
just want to make you settle down like i
just come straight up be like you know
baby i ain't [ __ ] to be like
but maybe he changed everything
i'd be like maybe he changed
oh god he was doing a fuckboy
i believe it yeah yeah
[ __ ] i ain't [ __ ] now i'm just kidding
i swear
i'm good okay oh my god okay uh who
would have the most interesting stories
to tell on mari what the daddy stuff
or just like i feel like your stories
would be
just interesting really because you
don't look like somebody that would have
an interesting story like cool like no
but you look like really like
put together
calm collected and then like wow i get
to see people like crazy yeah
i mean we look like crazies yeah we look
like the people screaming i told you you
was the dad
i told you you didn't want to believe me
but i told you
see we look like that
you know what i'm saying like they would
look at us like this [ __ ] is she lying
or we know that
that is definitely baby mama yeah that's
funny
okay i'll take it because it's like
you could surprise somebody yeah i would
love to see that yeah unless they get
paid they get paid to be on mario right
yeah
it's for sure fake
yeah i have one who is most frequently
awake at 4 00 am
the both of you that's true the both of
you for complete opportunities
me too because i have an infant oh
that's true oh damn it so you guys have
good reasons
and you're on tv for this reason that's
true come on girl you're a gamer this is
true this is this is all good
who will end up practicing a religion
that they didn't grow up believing in
probable me
i was raised as a buddhist
ah
but hear me out so
that's why i looked at you hear me out
okay i've been reading into i'm not
interested in practicing i've been
reading into different religions the
church of satanism is kind of [ __ ]
dope oh lord don't you isn't it all
about like individuality individuality
and like it's like you're not worshiping
the devil or satan the teachings are
actually pretty [ __ ] cool yeah
there's another religion that is about
worshiping the devil and it's not same
thing yeah but then everyone's like oh
it's satan i'm like no it's not really
not at all
but also you could get um you could go
into the whole thing about like well
yeah that's the devil playing tricks on
you yeah i mean [ __ ] people say that
[ __ ] all the time so we are going with
gina yeah
um who would fail at an 8th grade math
exam if we took one right now oh bro 1
000 right here
my son just finished the eighth grade
and i take a peek at his homework and
i'm like nah they got that new math
that's why that's why look at that
common core is ridiculous yeah they got
new math oh
it's not the regular math you know
what's so funny oh i can't damn it i
brought this up and i can't even retell
it properly but the point is there was a
situation and isaac was doing math to
get the answer for the situation
and then i looked at him and i'm like
that was the long way like you could
have just gone like from here to here
and he's like what no it's so easy you
just go from here to here to here to
here
here but you guys have the same answer
it's the same answer but that's what
common core is like they literally make
you go through like a million million
steps yeah and then i'm like what the
[ __ ] how do you know and but i'm glad he
finds it easy because holy crap i can't
yeah my dungeons and dragons character
um her kind uh they look like kids and
they act like kids you know but they can
be like 100 year olds you know and
they're just like these fun like things
yeah and every time i roll my dice i
have to count with my fingers how cute
and then my my co-host my co-mate and my
cast mates are like it is so cute that
you you do that in character i'm like
listen
that's not curious
don't you hate when you have to
acknowledge your downfall i had to tell
i'm learning i'm learning golf right and
i had to tell my instructor he kept
saying left and right i said look i'm
going to say forward and back
because look you can't say this left or
right [ __ ] because you're like left
[ __ ] real confused
no my ass goes like this
so that you don't do this in front of
people
so front foot back foot that's all i
know back foot front foot
stay left wait which one's back and
which one's front for you right is front
no right back
right his back left is front so when i'm
standing in the batter's box and when
i'm standing towards the t right is
always back so that's why i was like
don't say around left
see front and back
that's so funny you should we everything
he teaches me i literally switch it into
a language i know i'm going to be like
like that's all fun he's like yes palm
forward you mean push it he's like
okay push it yeah
he's not making notes okay
this goes slow
[Laughter]
this one seems it's kind of easy
who has been binge watched an entire
season of a tv show without leaving the
house
multiple times yeah same multiple yeah
all of us yeah so easy oh my gosh
umbrella academy when that came out
i had to watch it yeah the boys the boys
i just keep hearing about it
crazy oh my god the boys gives me the
same feeling that rick and morty gives
me oh like i'm like how do people come
up with this [ __ ] yeah
this recent season was nuts here yeah
give me some new ones i'm down for some
okay so i'm opening up the drunk
stoneder stupid extreme pack oh yeah
yeah so here you go thank you mm-hmm
we're just going to mash up a bunch of
games
okay
okay how are you going
i mean
it literally says
literally did meth
because all it says is literally did
math
nope
nope no no okay but out of the three of
us who do you think i think gina would
try probably yeah yeah i think you would
try it i gotta i'm curious you know but
i'm just scared of trying it because
like i heard it's really addictive but
i'm like curious about things you know
same yeah i think i kinda did oh
i gotta remember the old version of you
like there's like there's like this
whole other side to you yeah like a
whole another lifetime ago yeah so
during that lifetime i was in high
school um i was it was one of those
ditching days when we all went to a
friend's house
and this guy he would smoke meth out of
a pipe oh [ __ ] oh my goodness
and then so he said like he had just
finished or whatever i'm like i want to
try it what does it taste like or
whatever like do you have more he's like
no i finished it but you could have the
residual whatever whatever is in the
pipe
so
we i lit it up and then i got something
oh damn do you feel like
i don't know like it just i can't even
remember now mm-hmm yeah good don't
remember that yeah i don't remember that
i just remember i had a taste like it
had a flavor damn
that was it so i don't know i guess i
get that card i literally did yeah yeah
yeah i don't know i don't i honestly
don't think i even got anything to even
have any sort of reaction you can use or
like a feeling or anything i don't know
wow these are
these are really funny these are just so
funny okay um
oh my god i almost like not looking at
him though like there's a part of me
that just like doesn't want to look and
then just
here we'll pick out of each other's okay
by far the ugliest person in the group
it's not even close oh damn wow
no no
these are these are intense
makes a strong case for why the human
race ultimately won't survive oh my god
yeah okay hold on okay first of all
pollution
and also we are dumb as [ __ ] dude like
we keep [ __ ] [ __ ] up we keep
littering we're trying like new
medication and does weird [ __ ] to people
like freaking gmo foods yeah yeah we're
dying yeah absolutely dying but i'm
going to go with them
gina yeah
oh sorry i'm supposed to here you go
[Music]
[Laughter]
wanting to do some freaky [ __ ] with you
and she comes with a tub of yogurt
prepare for death
and if she's like don't worry baby i
just want to put a little in your butt
she's going to kill you she's prepping
for something she's prepping so gina
tries to put yogurt in your
kink butt like a cake
okay uh who gets vanilla at ben and
jerry's
you yeah oh my god
i love vanilla vanilla is good but you
know it's funny that like we know it's
you yeah yeah i actually didn't really
care for vanilla until casey convinced
me how bomb vanilla is you know what it
is so now it's like a favorite ice cream
flavor in our home yeah vanilla i can't
even stand the smell of like vanilla air
fresheners
wow oh wait i got you on that
yeah i don't really i'm not a huge fan
of vanilla scents same with cherry oh my
god it can't stand cherry
rocky roads my [ __ ] i love rocky road
how old are you still eight
you're either eight or eighty if you
like rocky road you know i can't pick a
favorite ice cream flavor i have too
many i don't even know you don't have
like your one go-to like i have my one
that when somebody asked it's um
chocolate malted crunch from thursdays
like that's my go-to i love that i put a
little bit of milk when i mix it up but
what about like
generic ones like when you go to an ice
cream shop
what's your go-to flavor
coffee
that's a good one haagen-dazs coffee is
pretty damn so good yeah i have too many
i love i love pistachio coconut coconut
pineapple
strawberry vanilla yeah um oh uh this is
a mexican one is the pecan butter pecan
one
that's
yeah my dad likes it too
so good and they got the little crunchy
bits oh
okay all right sidetracked oh here you
pool
cat why do you have the dumbest look on
your face right now dude oh he does he
get that card of the
you're the ugliest little [ __ ] thing
in the world here hold this card real
quick
yeah here we go here hold that card can
you give him that card just tuck it
under him my dog is going to be so mad
at ugly yes
uh we'll take a pillow to grandma's face
after making sure they're in the will
wait we'll take it take a pillow
oh [ __ ]
yeah gina
i already hate that [ __ ] i would do it
for a promise of [ __ ] half a
mcchicken
okay she said if i get a bite her
sandwich
oh my god
hold on i gotta take a picture of my cat
right now because he looks so silly hold
on nobody moved nobody
shout out to our sponsor hellofresh with
hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
so skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun and affordable that's why it's
america's number one meal kit i recently
had the sesame peanut noodles oh my god
have you even tried do you even live
life it's so good charred bell pepper
slices carrots peanut butter sauce it
tastes like i ordered it from a
restaurant which is incredible because
guess what i'm not a restaurant if you
can imagine you can gear up for the busy
fall season with 55 less weekly options
and take the stress out of meal planning
and prepping from family friendly to fit
and wholesome and even veggie as i just
mentioned i like all the vegetarian
dishes sesame peanut noodles has been my
most recent fave but there are so many
other dishes that are just super quick
super easy and super delicious need
another reason to stay in for dinner
hello fresh is 72 cheaper than dining at
a restaurant and is even cheaper than
grocery shopping that's money back in
your pocket
hello go to hellofresh.com bigmood16 and
use code bigmood16 for 16 free meals
across seven boxes and three free gifts
that's right you can get 16 free meals
across seven boxes and three free gifts
by going to hellofresh.com
big mood 16 and using code big mood 16.
okay who is obviously an only child
none of us
i
originally was an only child i am pretty
i should have been
you should
i acted like i was an only child for a
long time i didn't know but i was really
upset when my sister was born oh
so my mom
i love you mom i'm so sorry that i'm an
[ __ ] um
when my sister was born
i peed myself at the hospital
and told my dad to take me home how old
were you three oh my goodness and and my
dad took me home my mom was like
apparently i said dad i'm ready to go
home oh wow and my dad took me home
you're that one girl i went with that
birthday vlog
or like what blew out the candle yeah
yeah that's you that's me that's you
yeah wait how does that happen
dang so you're just like i don't care i
was here three years without you
why are you here i was fine we were all
fine and i do say three years apart too
close and too far mm-hmm that's not good
not a good amount of time tell me what's
a good amount
back to back your opinion i would say my
sister had uh me and bria back to back
so sister had you and me no no my sister
had mia oh mia and bria oh so her her
daughter's kind of a back to back and i
think that's really like hot time apart
uh maybe like a year oh wow yeah so
they're really really close in age and i
feel like that's better than three i
think you got to go more than three or
less
and i think that's just
it makes more sense because we were
close in age but still in different
grades yeah so like the expectations she
wanted to do all the things that i could
do i didn't understand why she was able
to it was just really weird but i would
say if i could i would do back to back
yeah because i hear that too close could
be bad too
because then it's like
like there are practically like 20s or
whatever but you know i see how my
nieces are and how my sisters
is with them and i'm like they have such
a better relationship than we had it's
like older sister younger sister versus
like siblings mine is five years apart
me and my sister she's my half sister
but we are so close i would say like i
think three is too close yeah it's like
not close enough but still too close
yeah that's a weird weird amount of time
but my brother and i five years is
better yeah yeah
i have a lot of siblings but i don't
really i didn't really grow up with any
of them same yeah i have nine there's
like nine twelve damn yeah yeah so six
for my dad
three for my mom
damn no wait five for my dad three for
my mom i get like that too i'm like one
from me
left right all right
i'll do it okay
would be a fun person to torture
you
yeah i think so i think you would be fun
to torture for sure how i don't know in
all ways fun
i don't like i feel like i'd probably
yeah i think you'd be fun hmm
i feel like you would kind of go along
with it or like oh like actually being
fun no no like being tortured you okay
torture like yeah i feel like
you would probably like some things that
we think would be torture oh cause i'm
thinking like if i was in the mindset of
a murderer yeah he would scream the
louder that's what i would bring me much
joy but i still think that she would
kind of giggle at certain things because
she would like surprise you i just feel
like she would surprise you while you're
doing some stuff
yeah
what are you gonna do with those
electric cables right like she's like
yeah like she might just all of a sudden
just ah oh my god no don't do it
don't pull out my toenails yeah
just gives me like some surprise advice
like i would like to see what you know
let's explore
i like that yeah i think i agree
i might surprise you
yeah all right let me see
likes it big
that [ __ ] hurts all right nikki yep it's
naked she likes it she likes that [ __ ]
hurts
i like my cervix intact you can handle
that that's all you that's all you do
yeah
i don't know hello
it's me hello it's me
can't do it can't do it that [ __ ] hurts
lazy sack of [ __ ]
that's a nibbler oh my god how cute is
he's playing
his paws are like this
that's so adorable best life oh yeah
i love how he's on the cards
okay okay
um oh you got a black one i could do
this
needs a muzzle to stop the profuse
stream of [ __ ] that flows out of their
word hole
and we just we just are we just gonna
avoid eye contact thanks for watching
our podcast
it's true that's why we're
i got a tweet once that made me laugh so
hard they said
i can't believe they just let you on the
internet unsupervised i'm like i know
i know
i have no idea why and i just won an
award like i just got told yesterday
that i'm winning an award for uh cool
like internet personality or something
or like ambassador personality i'm like
are you sure yeah like you've seen my
tweets right
my tweets think they think i'm jumping
off a bridge daily like she is so sad oh
man i just feel like i just think sad
stuff all the time i'm not really sad
that's funny no if i really if i would
actually say all the things i think
about i would probably get um welfare
checks out we would all get
institutionalized you could
institutionalize
all of us for sure immediately yeah
uh we'll take advantage of someone's
cancer wish jesus christ
[Applause]
yeah we gonna pass that one pull another
fun story okay so i used to come okay i
gotta i got a cancer story for you huh
um
when i was competing in beauty pageants
when i was a teenager
um the woman that won the year before
she so you know the one that wins the
year before always comes and passes on
her crown
her name was virginia i remember this
um and then so you know pageant years
are over and then around like 23 24
years old
news
around like starts starts spreading
she became a nurse and one of her
patients
died from cancer
she stole her ipad
and then the cops tracked it to her
house and she changed the ipad name to
virginia's ipad wow she stole a cancer
patient's ipad wow how wild is that that
just lets us know you beauty pageant
queens are really evil crazy yeah angry
yeah there was no need to include that
um
i remember like i was uh we were in
preliminaries and i went to the bathroom
and then i like was washing my hands
next to this girl and i'm like wow
there's some really pretty girls here
she goes i think everyone here is so
beautiful in their own way
[ __ ] there are no judges in the stalls
right now can you calm down she's like a
practicing line yeah [ __ ] crazy so
fake and she ended up winning because
her
uh like they had like an award like her
dad donated the most to the pageant
that's a weird thing to put out there
yeah she probably happily got that
trophy too yeah
weird okay who wants to touch my deck
don't touch your deck really enjoys
giving a nice thorough [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i love how you look at each other
i'm going to vote gina what
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
was
that look up who's gonna say first
i mean
i mean you know we don't want to admit
to this you know you know you don't want
to admit to it like i've denied did not
deny it i think it's gross i don't like
you but if i love you i've never seen
one i don't know what that is what is
this get that away from me
i don't even like it
i heard someone say recently that when
you love someone there is no body part
that you would not put in your mouth
except eyeballs so don't be looking
eyeballs oh [ __ ] there's something
body
you would lick the inside of a nostril
yeah
yeah sometimes like we're annoying
girlfriends i'm gonna sit there in bed
just digging around can't sleep [ __ ]
stick my tongue up your nostrils wake up
pay attention i'm the type of one to be
like i go to sleep holding it yeah the
same same because balls are squishy and
they're fine yeah like a little like
it's like a it's like you know like
people like to play with slime yeah this
is squishy it's like and especially when
it's warm and yeah it's firmed up and if
you are mine
yeah i'm the type to walk around in
public grabbing and be like hmm mm-hmm
let's go
i do not care if a leash is from
yes if i could if i could i would oh a
thousand percent oh super annoying oh if
i love you
yeah the only reason i've been told to
like go to sleep [ __ ] go go to bed
leave me alone leave me alone you ain't
i said wake up
i'm one of those like i just look at you
and poke it and you always get that
they're always like
yeah they'd be like what's wrong with
you i say you
oh
one time i complained i was like he's
like what's wrong i'm like
there's nothing to argue about it's
bored like
something you just gotta
that was unhealthy gina
okay you just got it from yesterday
from yesterday
you don't want to know why i said you oh
[ __ ]
because of your um your thoughtfulness
oh
this is your thoughtfulness that goes
around this your thoughtfulness of
blow drops oh god i give good [ __ ]
because i'm thoughtful but because
because
of the wax that you put it behind your
teeth
no we've talked about this before i
don't know yeah but this this is a this
is recent developments here so i have a
brace in the back of my front teeth on
top
and i'm always so afraid of like
scraping yeah so i asked myself
and i was like can i have that the
braces wax to just smooth it over yeah
and then like my dentist is like my
friend he goes oh what for i'm like
oh that's so sweet of you
i don't think i'm that nice
first off you know you're gonna get over
this
you're gonna like this scrappy
description
[Laughter]
doctors for your [ __ ] i remember when
that episode came out imagine that
argument like god that oh
well that would probably be my husband
but i'm so cute i know that my dentist
even watched my show our show
and he messaged me he's like i'm [ __ ]
dying like what happened i just saw the
episode were you talking about wax i was
like oh no
like you just crossed the line now
because now i'm gonna talk to you about
everything yeah yeah
yeah you [ __ ] up you open pandora's
box
okay uh doesn't care what their parents
think what the law is or if they're
technically your cousin
oh
that's gross you throw it the last one
really curves there
yeah yeah
uh is an unloyal hoe
hmm
you you will [ __ ] sell me out in a
minute
he grabbed him he's like that's me he's
like yeah that's mine yeah
he's eating it oh too bad the camera
can't see oh my gosh that's hilarious
okay
uh we'll make a great
what
i don't want to read this huh we'll make
a great pedophile no
no
no no way
[Applause]
who claims that they could quit their
bad habits immediately if only they
wanted to
um
yeah gina i vote gina yeah votes gina
yeah for sure yeah for sure
where's your favorite percent
quitter okay
if you wanted to you could you wanted to
you're taught me not to quit don't ever
be a quitter
uh would be the clear first choice to be
sacrificed by the group
i don't know why you're for what reason
but yeah who why why would i feel like
if we're like sacrificing like
sacrificing you know like the innocent
virgin one always dies that would be you
even though you're not a virgin but
still you know you're the sweet innocent
one that we would sacrifice first i need
her to survive yeah i'm the only one
who's going to be alive
uh
to be sacrificed me it would be like i
offered myself like i said yeah i'm out
she raises her hand yeah we're like whoa
me please me sir some of you are trying
to sway the vote yeah
yo
i don't know why y'all keep trying to
vote this one out i said i will go
dude i remember when i was people like
this
i remember when i was a kid and we would
vote for like
for like class whatever like in
elementary school like class whatever it
would come down to two and i remember it
came down to me and the other person
and my ass voted the other person
because i wanted to be nice oh and they
won and they were that one vote yeah and
i'm just like
why do i do this
you know i wanted it but i'm like i want
to be nice and i'm like i would believe
that he would do the same thing for me
because you know it's arrogant to vote
for yourself and that's a hard lesson
that i learned in life about
self-sacrifice okay and being nice
people
you didn't learn [ __ ] because you're
still so nice yeah
um
don't read another card
uh we'll put their kid up for adoption
if ugly
[Laughter]
he's asymmetrical get him out oh damn
damn
damn find a new mommy find a new mom
daddy comes right out she'll be like
that's not mine
she looks at her man like so you've been
cheating
so you've been cheating
who the [ __ ] you been sleeping with
because the way my eyes are set up
they're better than that
well lopsided i asked [ __ ] have you
been [ __ ] around i know my head is
big but not that big what is this okay
it's still got the umbilical cord she
said what is this
i mean
i didn't give birth to that that's not
mine he's like
he's over here looking at himself he's
like i didn't realize i had one lazy
action that is my kid that's so funny
jenna would look at me be like look at
probably the baby daddy and go oh i
should have knew your ass was ugly i
knew you were plastic surgery didn't jim
[Music]
jenna would sue her baby
who would be the most delicious person
to eat in the group
um
i've had your boob milk before you work
out so your meat is too tough i know i'm
too firm yeah i know
you got good meals you got good milk
you're nutritious but you're squishy
okay
what i'm squishy no no like squishy with
like tender tenderness oh because i
don't move i'm like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's interesting to talk yourself
[Applause]
so you're soft
shake my ceiling real quick
oh stop it
we're like yeah we've had your breath
smoke she's like you don't work out yeah
right no it is true though i would be
like the kobe beef
exactly i get massages i lay around
okay that's true yeah yeah that's true
it would be delicious delicious but you
come with like
good nutrition you are like we've
already sampled it that's why yeah great
i don't even know you taste yeah
super down for cheaper sneakers if
they're made by kids in a sweatshop oh
wow
that's weird that's weird yeah i don't
think anyone should answer that
you're like oh i think we all should
just like killing grandma yeah [ __ ] that
we're all answering that kid sweatshop
no grandma bye absolutely she's lived
long enough
um whose upbringing had the least amount
of influence on their life choices
nah i think all of us yeah yeah
we're products of our environment yeah
yeah here are you pool
we'll suck you off for a dime sack um
who's in the room is it is that between
between the three of us
i mean it was a tough time
you said you would do some [ __ ] for a
bite of a chicken sandwich okay
what is in the bag what is in the sack
what's in the second diet
what is in there
second time
we can afford this now nikki
but if we in the room i need some
options i'd be like
free it's free
you know i'm changed you know the fault
it's not the first time i said dick for
cracking oh my gosh
what is that from who knows that
reference wait what is it
wait the first it's not the first time i
suck a dick for crack and it won't be
the last oh my gosh
but i want to do that
i was just watching the first season oh
so good recently um we'll make really
yummy cookies and not give you any
huh
who would do that
hmm
we're sharing people i need you to
understand how good i am at everything
yeah
he's clearly just doing it
i'm just doing i'm just really great
because i need compliments
i don't care if you're allergic you're
gonna eat these cookies
i mean gluten vegan
pescatarian
cookies
okay uh who will get into a fight with
an elderly person and lose
you don't lose gina
gina would pick a fight with the wrong
grandma i would pick we'll fight with
yeah yeah sure she said she would this
is true i would fight the elderly if i
had yeah for a chicken sandwich i've
yelled at some
okay here you go
[Laughter]
impressively stupid
y'all leave your comments
i would like to see what y'all have to
say about that one she's like cause i
can't decide again
she said so many stories from both oh my
god she can't decide
no it's not me i'm surprised if you're
smart here we go
will forget to tell the neighbors that
they're a registered sex offender oh my
god
probably
i don't need them in my business yeah
okay oh yeah i forgot i forgot to do
this but honestly it would probably be
out of like i would straight up just
forget yeah because i forget everything
yeah
that is actually hilarious it's gonna
bite your dick off
depending on the situation
yeah yeah
i think i would put gina over nicky
though yeah
yeah even though she's considerate like
yeah yeah she's still more likely to
bite it off you're pretty bitey yeah
pretty bitey like if if if they wronged
you yeah
you will seduce to kill yeah yeah this
is true
hey baby let me throw some yogurt on
your phone
let me try something new real quick i
heard it right really good lube
you're getting real toothy over here you
know it makes it taste better if you're
it's like did this [ __ ] put gloves on
too much what is happening
[Laughter]
what happily snapped the neck of a
hundred baby bunnies for a brand new bmw
5 series with the um i performance
package
a hundred bunnies though you gotta kill
a hundred bunnies
i've actually seen that in person i'm
sorry why oh
cookers yeah my grandpa would he he
raised bunnies to sell in his home and
once i saw him murder
hey bunny
and then made bunny soup and i did not
eat it okay so that's a no for you i
think i would have cried but i would
still try it actually i didn't visually
i heard it because he was a scream
because he was gonna do it and he's like
why did you just look so happy when you
said that
[Applause]
oh so we got her answer gina recently
this is this crazy [ __ ] is what she
said no she even got giddy she's like
got up gina you're a guy
and everything you get that card
wow can we move on because that was that
was scary she was scary i've been saying
that if i'm not super famous by the time
i'm 40 i'm gonna become a serial killer
y'all got seven years okay god well
you're already you're i mean you're on
tv you're oh i think we're okay we're
safe we're getting talking a-list there
okay that's seven years [ __ ]
we all died seven years on buying yogurt
if you see this [ __ ] on a yo player
just know she killed everybody on set to
get that job
okay um
who will marry someone who isn't born
yet
um
gina no young guys you dated someone
young recently
oh that was a disaster that's never
happening ever again and that was like a
fluke that was a one-off okay because
i've always dated older guys but i
really believe
if you're still single when you're older
you will most definitely maybe cougar it
yeah yeah your favorite you know for
sure yeah
shows early signs of being a serial
killer
she just admitted to it hold your card
the last three cards put this on a shirt
yeah just keep that right there like
instead of your driver's license just
hand that over to the police be like you
may not know why i'm doing this now but
you'll know why later
at seven years like man what is this for
don't worry you'll thank me later yeah
when when you discover who didn't yeah
the signs were all there just just keep
this solve it
okay uh we'll be sad if their sibling
gets cancer because that means they
might get cancer
jesus christ
oh i don't think so what
genetics genetics i'd be saying
yeah but i'm scared but i mean that not
for god yeah
that's one of those that we're like be
sad if they're i don't get it if they're
sibling just you would be sad because
you could possibly get cancer yeah
because they have cancer right because
you're afraid that you might get it
yeah
but you wouldn't care about that more
than you're simply oh no i would care
about my sibling more yeah yeah yeah oh
i see i see yeah the angle yeah that's
why we're all like a bad one i'm a
little slow i could win that stupid card
she's like i vote for myself
another vote another one for me we know
the answer now
damn i wish we all could have had one
card that perfectly describes us
yeah well this one's mine who will
become a liability after the fewest
number of drinks yeah that's you for
sure
yes i'm real good at holding my drinks
this is not me but it says destin to
live in a storage unit
oh who's that i don't know but that was
just the one i picked
parents knew they made a huge mistake
now my parents are grateful for me
oh here we go only has pity sex
thinks they have a really big penis
yeah
oh yeah i had the drinks one let me see
who clogs the toilet at their friend's
house and says nothing oh my god
should just cut their losses and sell
their body parts for me
because you're soft why you you're soft
your wagyu body that still was [ __ ] up
tiff
here claire's always be sacrificed i
didn't know they were a prostitute
that would be you
you would hang out with this prostitute
and just be like she's so nice so in
conclusion i feel like this has happened
to me probably probably
yeah so we've learned a lot about each
other today mm-hmm that was fun
definitely solidified that this is the
killer of the group yep um this is the
gullible one yep and hi the survivor
survivor
oh we have like a whole movie going on
right now it's like
you're among us you know you guys never
guess it's me
well i mean yeah you would but you know
everyone has a role yeah who would die
first
yeah but we'd like to see you less we
would like to see you later only because
i'm a mother you're going to be the one
that like dies first but everyone's like
no
if we wanted her around longer
family oh no and she had a baby she was
so sweet
um okay that was really fun thank you
guys so much for watching yeah
nikki tell them where they can find you
you can find me everywhere at nikki
blaze we'll just keep it real simple go
to my instagram i keep you updated over
there and um let's be friends check out
the description for her links
and check out our sponsors in
description also we love you we'll see
you guys next time be good i did not
kill anyone yeah allegedly legally
obligated
but if you are a younger if you are a
yogurt company we are looking for
sponsors yeah hey what's up
[Music]
you